à
[Musique]
c'est l'un des meilleurs danseurs des
yvelines il s'appelle bambino il nous
vient de trappes ce danseur qui est
tombé dans la culture hip hop il y à 12
ans ou bien prendre sa revanche lors de
cette deuxième édition du battle bin
jawwad attrape vérité bon rotor natar du
premier tour n'est en fait on a eu
ex-aequo début sa liste égalité et avait
un passage supplémentaire afin
d'interroger c'est pas ça chez compte et
pour cette deuxième édition le
trappistes va danser avec son binôme
avec qui il parcourt la france depuis
cinq ans et pour remporter le battle
qu'ils ont un plan non n'est pas
technique mon épée sur le ressenti de la
musique samedi on va pisser laisser se
laisser aller par rapport à la musique
et on va essayer de prendre la musique
et de montrer ce que l'on sait faire
notre style à nous par rapport à la
musique c'est ça c'est de l'impro il ya
beaucoup de nous on est plus sur le free
style comme on dit en épisodes freestyle
lyonnaises ont des passages préparé mais
nous on est plus triste elle voudrait
faire et on a des petits trucs à nous
les petits on va dire des petites face
qui sont à nous qu'on connaît qu'on
allait sortir
mais sinon et beaucoup de tristesse
bambino s'entraîne tous les jours pour
la deuxième édition du battle be the one
le battle se déroule le samedi 3
décembre à 15 heures 30 à la halle
culturel de la merise attrape les
vainqueurs remporteront 200 euros
[Musique]